siete pronti per scatenare un po di
felicità
si chiama música vanni mani siamo
l'energia è l'energia del esserlo
evviva
sono onorato di essere qui e di far
germogliare nel vostro cuore un po di
gioia un po di felicità
del resto questo è anche un po mio
lavoro è anche la mia missione è quello
di aiutare le persone nel mondo
a scatenare questa energia vitale che
abbiamo già dentro di noi
l'energia della felicità pensate che
quando ero a puttaparthi nel sud
dell'india dove ho abitato con la mia
famiglia per diversi anni
proprio lì in india in questo villaggio
sperduto ho incontrato per serendipità
questa tecnica meravigliosa la tecnica
che ti permette di ridere senza aver
bisogno di alcun motivo per farlo
straordinario lemon ieri da quando mi
guardo in faccia ad esempio no è un buon
motivo per la certo si ridere però sono
rimasto felicemente entusia entusiasmo
dalla magia della risata incondizionata
perché ti permette di ridere soprattutto
quando le cose non vanno proprio come tu
vorresti è importante ricordarsi che da
bambini ridavano in media 300 400 volte
al giorno
perché mai perché ce lo ricorda persino
la scienza medica quello ufficiale
quando noi ridiamo e il nostro corpo
secerne queste sostanze incredibili
produce quella che è stata definita la
chimica della felicità e questa è
straordinario
pensate che la scienza ha scoperto e non
troppo recentemente che quando noi ci
lasciamo ridere si abbassa il cortisolo
che è l'ormone dello stress pury di meno
sei stressato ma soprattutto abbiamo
osservato che quando noi ci lasciamo
ridere è il nostro diaframma fa un
movimento molto importante che va a
spingere va a passeggiare i polmoni e
permette ai polmoni di buttare fuori
anidride carbonica per inspirare
maggiore quantità di ossigeno e questo è
fondamentale perché sappiamo che a
ridere ti permetti di ossigenare al
cento per cento le tue cellule questo ci
permette di rimanere in salute ma direi
proprio di scatenare la nostra energia
vitale vedete oggi io non sono qui a
fare bla bla bla bla ma a fare con voi
uomo fa ma perché questo è il manto
il sacro della felicità vi ricordate il
suono della risata straordinario era
quando tu ridi e la gente nel mondo mi
dice ma tu non sei un cabarettista come
possiamo ridere lo so come si fa ridere
ridendo ok avete voglia di scatenare un
po di risata e allora un piccolo
esercizio braccia in avanti
ora vi chiedo di portare le vostre
braccia verso di voi e inspirare mo
centrate su l'area qua dei buchi del
naso va bene ma ispira l'attività tinta
di naso fuori le braccia ridendo il pari
tutto dell'agio vai ispira fratini
tadini da tiri fuori la risata un po più
forte va in stiva trattieni trattini tra
temi non stai morendo tratte vivai vedi
è straordinariamente semplice e quando
tu ridi e il tuo corpo fisico sprigiona
l'energia dell'entusiasmo della felicità
e quando noi cambiamo come corpo cambia
anche la nostra attitudine mentale ma
signore e signori poiché sono ascoltate
siamo quì in questo mondo meraviglioso
per scatenare gioia questa è la nostra
ultima destinazione la gioia un altro
esercizio
facciamo così con le mani facciamo la
cuffia noi gli auricolari la cuffia
appoggiano alle orecchie ora vi chiederò
di ridere e li ascolterete ridere se non
funzionerà è perché non state ridendo e
scientifico vai là visivi ora ancora la
cuffia alzate l'antenna così siete
connessi all universo vai ai wifi
fatevi un applauso bravi
wow
certo quando tu ridi cambi e quando tu
cambi il mondo cambia con te vedete
ridere è davvero straordinario perché ci
riporta sempre i momenti più belli
dell'esistenza e le persone dicono ma io
sto vivendo un momento veramente
difficile
nella mia vita si chiedono alcun perché
per ridere appunto ora stai scoprendo
che puoi ridere lasciandoti
semplicemente andare vi propongo un
altro esercizio vi va di farlo con me vi
prego ora di appoggiare entrambe le mani
qui al centro del vostro cuore quale
spirituale se vi va se chiudete anche
gli occhi ascoltate questa voce che ora
vi guiderà alcuni mi definiscono un po
uno sherpa uno sherpa dell'anima cerca
di percepire il contatto con il tuo
cuore che batte e ora ti chiedo di
portare tutto il tuo respiro esattamente
lì nel tuo cuore che batte respira e
porta l'attenzione sul quale fisico
quando inspiri
percepisce chiaramente questa energia
vitale che ti sostiene
chiediamoci chi ti alimenta e quando
esami quando ispiri lascia fuoriuscire
ogni problema ogni dubbio ogni paura
quando inspiri percepisci questa energia
meravigliosa che ti ama che ti sostiene
e quando esa ii lascia fuoriuscire ogni
dubbio ogni angoscia maniera almaric
coraggio
ancora una volta inspira che se energia
meravigliosa trattenere in tema e ora
lascia andar fuori ogni paura ogni di
sentimento cerca di percepire il livello
del tuo corpo della tua energia
interiore meraviglioso mangino gli occhi
chiusi e ora ti chiedo di portare questa
energia a tutti i tuoi cari
ovunque siano immagina di poter
riabbracciare con questa energia
meravigliosa osservano ovunque sono
avvolgi lì in questa energia di
gratitudine di amore ora ti chiedo di
immaginare il volto di tua madre è anche
quello di tuo padre
al di là di ogni cosa che può essere
accaduta tra di voi
ti invito ad abbracciarli con questa
energia e se puoi perdonali ma
soprattutto ringraziali per il sacro
dono che ti hanno fatto di avere questo
corpo
ora ti prego di estendere tutta questa
energia
a tutti i tuoi amici
i tuoi conoscenti alle persone che sono
qui in questo teatro meraviglia
all'anca questa consapevolezza senti
l'energia che vivrà in ogni singolo
atomo della tua pelle del tuo corpo
porta tutta questa energia questa luce a
tutto questo mondo agli abitanti di
questo pianeta terra sprigiona la tua
gioia ora senti il tuo amore continua ad
alimentare questa gioia percepisci porta
questa luce un lume con te e ora sorride
solo dio
sorridi percepisce l'energia che
scaturisce nel tuo sorriso
dal tuo sorriso
delicatamente ora lascia andare le
braccia
delicatamente rehab i tuoi occhi
senti la tua energia vitale
genetico del mondo
è quello di contribuire a generare
felicità aiutando gli altri ha manco te
stesso
mi sento da allora questa energia che
trema in ogni singolo atomo nella tua
vita
il passato è passato il futuro incerto
ora è il momento più importante senza
ora nel campo fertile della tua mente
subcosciente il seme della
consapevolezza di ciò che fu sede dove a
ripetino con me ora è più forte più
energia
ora fatemi sentire con il vostro
applauso la porta energia coraggio
no
per ora infatti un porta fra uso se
farai questo troppo significa che
porterai a casa questa energia e la
porterà i due cari fatemi sentire
l'entusiasmo l'energia era certo
no grazie
e assieme e assieme che creiamo il
cambiamento è la cosa che come voi ho
imparato nella mia vita grazie a tante
sofferenze
grazie a un fallimento grazie a tanti
dolori grazie al fatto che da oltre
vent'anni mio babbo ed è nel cielo che
mi segue grazie a tutti questi maestri
che noi comunemente chiamiamo problemi
sfortune grazie a questi maestri ho
imparato la cosa più importante che
ognuno di noi alla libera scelta di
scegliere la felicità perché anche
l'infelicità è una scelta e chi compie
questa scelta sei tu questo è il seme da
far germogliare nella nostra vita tu sei
destinatario di questa gioia quando tu
punti dito verso gli altri
se facendo un errore enorme quando tu
dai una colpa agli altri
agli altri amici ai nemici alle
istituzioni alle altre religioni alle
altre persone che tu pensi siano
sbagliato se facendo un grande errore
perché stai ricordando la tua energia
agli altri della stai dando loro la
possibilità di decretare la felicità all
infelicità nella tua vita
quando tu punti dito verso di te se è il
centro del tuo cuore quando lo punti
verso gli altri ricordano come dicono in
india che ai tre dita che poi puntano
contro di tecnico non giudicare non
giudicare vivi la tua vita
dunque la detto degli altri quando tu
ridi cambi ridere non è the reader e
reader è l'espressione della gioia è
l'espressione dell'amore abramo che amo
isacco suo figlio colui che ride ma
allora facciamola finita con la
tristezza perché abbiamo ogni fonte ora
ora era più che mai per essere persone
realmente felici
perché come a voi neppure a me mancano
otto bicchieri di acqua potabile al
giorno
neppure a te manca almeno un passo
neppure a te manca un tetto sotto il
quale dormire sicuro a nessuno manca
l'ossigeno che è la fonte vitale di ogni
cosa
siamo già fortunati e allora rendiamoci
conto che questo mondo è meraviglioso
la bufera
l'uomo assieme
in più grazie
grazie
wow che bella energia
oramai sono in conclusione e non voglio
tenermi troppi segreti per me anzi sono
venuto qui a gettare anch'io i miei
colleghi gli altri spicca dei semi di
consapevolezza vi voglio lasciare con
questo chiede il resto mi ha lasciato il
momento spirituale in india a un giorno
fece questa domanda come posso innalzare
il mio tasso di felicità dal 51 per
cento al cento per cento è arrivata
questa intuizione che io vi dono perché
è bello condividere con l'umanità
le cose più belle della vita quando
possiamo innalzare la soglia della
nostra felicità quando mettendo in
pratica questo mantra lowball servo all
ama tutti servi tutti call per partner
aiuta sempre e non ferire mai
grazie